[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM SNEATH: We're going to
take the next little while
to talk through four
core areas of Flutter,
starting with designing
stunning apps with Flutter.
Then we're going to talk
about developing Flutter apps.
Then, we're going to talk
about connecting Flutter
to online services.
And lastly, we're going to talk
about the process of releasing
apps.
So let's start with design.
And to start this
section off, I'm
joined by Will Larche, who's an
engineer on the Material Design
team.
Will, great to see you.
[APPLAUSE]
WILL LARCHE: Thanks, Tim.
I'm so excited to
tell you today why
I believe that Flutter is the
perfect platform for executing
pixel-perfect designs.
But first, let's
take a step back.
Right now, good
design is expensive,
especially on mobile.
It takes extra engineering
resources to execute,
and what you get is
rarely what you want.
The designer hands us something
detailed and beautiful.
But we push back on
what makes it special.
Branded menu button?
It's easier to use a stock icon.
Custom map bar?
We could, but it's complex.
Custom tabs?
We ran out of time.
We end up compromising
on the details that
make our experience excellent,
and end up shipping something
that's just good enough, that
has the major features we
need but none of the finesse.
So with the best of intentions,
we say we'll get to it later.
But let's be honest,
later never comes.
The tickets sit in our
backlog, and we never
delete them because that
would be admitting defeat.
But what gets me so
excited about Flutter
is that we can break that cycle.
We can ship the app we really
want, with detail and polish,
and fewer of those
painful compromises.
Flutter's architecture
is designed
for building
beautiful, custom UI.
Flutter's main goal is to
make building polished,
custom app interfaces a faster,
more delightful experience
for designers and developers.
Firstly, Flutter
is powerful enough
to draw anything
designers dream up.
It's built on Skia, the
open-source graphics
engine used by Adobe,
Chrome, and Amazon Kindle.
We can get print-quality,
custom typography
without needing to dive down
to low-level frameworks,
like Core Text.
There's easy-to-access APIs
for character spacing and word
spacing.
Its animation and
motion framework
is more finely
tunable than anything
I've ever seen on mobile.
We've looked closely
at what developers
need to execute
complex, high-fidelity
designs on the devices of today,
and put it at their fingertips,
instead of burying it in
obscure, hard-to-learn
frameworks.
And we've used these APIs
to make a component library
expressing opinionated and
flexible design standards.
Material components for Flutter.
These are reusable widgets
designed by the Material Design
team here at Google.
If you haven't heard, we
released a major expansion
of Material, making the system
more flexible and expressive.
And the Flutter team
has done a great job
implementing the
Material components
to our specifications.
So we can get a
beautifully themed
experience out of the box.
On Flutter, Material
is beautiful.
It's a platform powerful
enough to build anything
our designers dream up.
It's also extensible.
We can extend the existing
Material components
to support almost anything.
And often, much more easily
than in traditional code.
But maybe most impressively,
Material is fast.
I actually built these
screens on the subway
on my way to work in
about half an hour.
The layout system in
Flutter is just that good.
I believe Material Design is
the most expressive and flexible
cross-platform design
system you could need.
But Flutter's powerful enough
to implement any design system,
so Material components
isn't the only library that
comes with Flutter.
You also get Cupertino,
a faithful implementation
of Apple's iOS design language.
Cupertino gives us
action sheets, alerts,
segment controls, sliders,
nav bars, switches--
over two dozen widgets
that look like they
came right out of UI kit.
But 100% open source.
And coming from traditional
iOS, that's mind-blowing.
If I have a question
about a text field,
I can go look at
its source code.
And you can't do that
with private APIs.
[LAUGHTER]
Cupertino even plays well with
Material components on iOS.
So I automatically get iOS style
controls when I run a Material
app on an iPhone.
But it doesn't matter if
you're using a design system
or a completely custom UI.
Flutter's faster than
traditional mobile coding.
In fact, we've seen
teams make up to 3x gains
in velocity using Flutter.
That could dramatically alter
what your team can accomplish.
And we've already
seen some of you
do amazing things with Flutter.
This is Reflectly,
an award-winning app
on iOS and Android, and
it's built with Flutter.
I'd like to invite
designer/developer Jacob
Kristensen, founder of
Reflectly, to join me on stage.
Jacob?
[APPLAUSE]
JACOB KRISTENSEN: Thank
you so much, Will.
So hello, everyone.
My name is Jacob.
I am a co-founder at
Reflectly, where I also
head up UX/UI design, as well
as front end development.
Now, Reflectly is what we call
a conversation-based journal.
Now, what that means is that
everyday users open up the app
and go through a series
of questions, which
helps them log down their day.
However, instead of
just presenting them
with a blank screen and
they fill in some text,
like you would in a
traditional journal, we
prompt them with very specific
UI instructions, such as rating
their day with little
a smiley face slider,
or selecting a icon that
best represented, well,
how their day went.
Now, all of this is
then bundled together
into what we call a Story.
Now, users can then go
back in their journal
and reread the story to
see what were they up to,
and how did they actually feel.
However, we can
also show them how
they've been progressing
over time by giving them
aggregated statistics.
Now, all this makes Reflectly
understandable and easy to use.
However, what's even
more important to
us is we're seeing it bringing
immense value to our users.
We're actually seeing users
become happier over time
by using Reflectly, which
of course, is amazing.
Now, Reflectly is
just around the corner
from hitting that 1 million
user mark, globally, all of whom
are able to use this amazing
app built entirely in Flutter.
WILL LARCHE: That's
really great, Jacob.
I want to ask you
a couple questions.
Was this your first Flutter app?
JACOB KRISTENSEN: Yes, it was.
WILL LARCHE: And how many
engineers were working on it?
JACOB KRISTENSEN: So just
me, for the front end.
WILL LARCHE: And how
long did it take you?
JACOB KRISTENSEN: So the
first line of Flutter
was written in March, and
with a learning curve,
we got this completed in
two and a half months.
WILL LARCHE: OK.
That's crazy.
Wow.
All right.
Great job, Jacob.
Thank you.
Jacob Kristensen.
[APPLAUSE]
I really believe we
might be entering
a new age, one in which
we don't tell designers
that we're going to be getting
to something later, or soon.
But now, Flutter makes executing
beautiful designs easy.
And with that, I'd like to
turn things back over to Tim.
Tim?
[APPLAUSE]
TIM SNEATH: So you've heard
how the architecture of Flutter
makes it possible for
designers and developers
to work together to
create beautiful UI.
And again, this is where
Flutter stands out,
as you saw with Philip's
demo in the Big History app.
It's the composition of
text, video, graphics, and UI
controls, whether from Flutter
or the underlying platform,
applying animations
and transformations
onto a single
hardware-accelerated surface
that makes Flutter such
a powerful platform,
and a powerful addition to
the tool kits of designers
and developers.
But while Flutter bridges
the gap to designers,
we think there's an opportunity
to give creative professionals
the same boost to productivity
that stateful hot reload gives
to developers.
And we've been working
with a company who've
been investing in this
space for a little while,
and they've got some
tools that I think
you might be interested to see.
So I want to invite
2Dimensions onto the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
GUIDO ROSSO: I'm a designer.
And what I really
like about Flutter
is how easy it makes
it for us to create
beautiful applications.
Now, as a designer, I
always have big plans
for what I'm going to build.
I love coming up with new
interactions, slick animations,
epic lens flares--
you name it.
That said, once I've
got these concepts down,
I then have to figure out how
I'm going to actually code
all of this awesome stuff.
And that's when I
think, how cool would it
be if I had a twin that
could code it all for me?
Well, I have good news.
Today, we are launching
a clone program.
[LAUGHTER]
Just kidding.
I am, indeed, lucky to have
a twin, and he's an engineer.
This is Luigi, by the way.
But thanks to our new
tool, and Flutter,
you won't need a
complimentary twin like us.
LUIGI ROSSO: We are
2Dimensions, and we're here
today to tell you guys
about a new product we
built called Flare.
Flare is a vector design and
runtime animation tool that
exports directly to Flutter.
Guido and I built
Flare so that designers
like ourselves and developers
can work in parallel.
GUIDO ROSSO: If
you're a designer,
the biggest
advantage to Flare is
that you don't need
to work-- that you
do get to work directly
on the assets that
run in your final app.
That means you don't need
to design in one app,
animate in another app,
red line your mock-ups,
write up a 100-page guide to
basically help your engineering
team redo all the work
that you already did.
Everything that
you design in Flare
is exactly what runs in Flutter.
Not only does this open
up your entire team
to be able to quickly
iterate, but it also
allows you to make great
design a part of your process
from the very beginning
right up until the completion
of your app.
So we have a demo, and
we're going to show you
how all of this works.
LUIGI ROSSO: So what Guido's
going to pull up here
is a Flutter list view
that's hooked up to a Flare
pull-down refresh animation.
Now, what you can see is, as
Guido pulls the list down,
there's a zoom animation
that progresses
with the movement of the list.
And at the same time,
there are a couple
different idle animations,
like the Earth spinning,
the stars twinkling,
and some of the comets
that are shooting by
that are blended on top.
GUIDO ROSSO: And this
is done regardless
of where Guido's
finger is placed,
or where the list
view is placed.
This is all animated
in different layers.
So this would all be
pretty difficult to achieve
with a video or
an image sequence.
Instead, these are all
animations that I created.
And I'm going to show
you a little bit of what
the file looks like in Flare.
So this is our space demo.
And these are all the animations
I created for this app.
There's this pull
animation, which
Luigi has hooked up
to basically progress
as you're pulling your finger.
And as you can see, the earth
isn't actually rotating.
The clouds and
continents aren't moving.
And that's because there's
a separate animation called
Idle here, and that's where
all that stuff is happening.
Now, if I blend these
two animations together,
you see that all that
stuff happens together.
The other animations
we have here
are just a simple
success state, which
basically happens when the users
pull their finger far enough.
It just lets the user know
something happened, success.
And then it goes into this
loading indeterminate state,
where it's basically waiting
for the loading to finish.
That's it.
That's all I created
in Flare, and Luigi
hooked that all up to work.
LUIGI ROSSO: So it only
takes a few lines of code
to get this actually
running in Flutter.
There are a bunch of widgets
that we provide that make
it really easy to do this.
And once this is done, Guido can
keep iterating on this design
completely by himself.
GUIDO ROSSO: That's
a good point.
So going back to the
simulator here, now
that I'm actually seeing
this running here,
I kind of think that the
moon spinning actually
looks sort of boring.
I think we could do something
a little more exciting with it.
And that's a good
opportunity to show you
guys how easily I can
update that, and iterate
on it, without taking
up any of Luigi's time.
So I'm going to
switch over to Flare.
And I'm in my loading
animation already.
I'm going to grab the moon
orbit key frames here,
and just hit Delete.
Now, what I actually want to do
is have the moon kind of move
from a side view.
I want it to move like this.
So I'm going to set a
key frame at the start
here for the position.
I'm going to set the same
key frame at the end.
And then, right about
in the middle here,
I'm going to put negative
60 to inverse it.
So now we've got the movement.
I'm going to add just
some easing to it.
And I want this to
be kind of playful,
so I'm going to go for a
bit of an exaggerated curve.
I already set up the draw
order so that it switches,
and you can see that we've
got our new orbit here.
Now, I'm going to do just one
last thing to really solve
this animation, and that's to
add just a little bit of scale
to make this look cartoony.
So I'm going to add
two key frames first
for our normal scale, and
then right about here,
where the moon is passing
in front of the earth,
I'm going to double our x.
And you'll see that this
creates just a little bit
of playfulness.
All right.
I think that's good
enough for now.
Let's see how I get
this back into Flutter.
Going to hit Export,
switch over to our assets,
and just drag-and-drop our
new asset over the old one.
Hit Replace.
And then I switch
over to VS code,
do a hot restart because we
need to reload our asset,
and we've got my new
moon animation in there.
[APPLAUSE]
I was able to do all of
that without taking up
any of Luigi's time, and I
can keep iterating on this
as long as I want.
LUIGI ROSSO: So
Flare is really good
that UI components, as well
as graphical animations,
like you just saw.
This is an expand-collapse
toggle animation
that Guido built for the
History of Everything app.
This is a broken heart that
shows up in the Favorites list
when it's empty.
But where Flare really shines
is at building complex animation
systems that are
really easy to control.
We have full support for
bones, constraints, and inverse
kinematics.
One of the animations
you may have
seen in the History
of Everything
is this Amelia Earhart.
She is controlled by
one set of constraints
that allow moving her eyes, her
nose, her mouth, and her face
without animating all of
those properties individually.
Instead, an animator can
really quickly key frame
just one node, or have
a developer control it
in Flutter, and have all
these constraints work there,
as well.
In this other example,
Guido can move the hip bone
for this character, and you can
see that her feet and her legs
bend and move in the correct
direction, as you'd expect,
and that's thanks to the inverse
kinematics that we support.
GUIDO ROSSO: So as
you can see, Flare
removes the churn between
design and development,
and it really allows you to make
great design a fundamental part
of your process.
I'm really excited to announce
that Flare is launching today
on 2Dimensions.com,
and it's free.
[APPLAUSE]
LUIGI ROSSO: If
you're a developer,
you'll be able to find a bunch
of assets on 2Dimensions.com
that other designers
have already shared
and made available on there.
In fact, all of the assets for
the History of Everything app
are available for free
on 2Dimensions.com.
We're really, really
excited to see
that Flutter is going
1.0 today, and we
can't wait to see how
you'll use Flare with it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM SNEATH: Wow.
Thanks, Luigi.
Thanks, Guido.
So that is Flare.
Flare bridges the gap between
designers and developers.
Designers are, at last,
able to fully participate,
from beginning to end, in
the development of an app,
creating interactive content
that can evolve along
with the rest of the app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]